environmentalists have been fighting to
cut the use of plastic straws and bags
for years now they're also focusing on
balloons because they say they're a
threat to wildlife releasing balloons
and large numbers is illegal in five
states and this year Rhode Island one
community they're banned the sale of and
use of all balloons other cities are
also introducing legislation now the
movements reached Clemson University
which for decades has started every home
football game
with its iconic balloon release mark
Strassmann is at Clemson football
stadium in South Carolina where the
future of balloons might be deflating
mark good morning good morning like all
big-time football schools Clemson is big
in its traditions and one of them easily
tomorrow when its players run down that
hill but longtime fans will look up and
notice that something's missing after 35
years the school is ending its massive
release of balloons
it's the latest sign of a rising
environmental debate Clemson's pregame
ceremony which includes releasing 10,000
balloons has been called the most
exciting 25 seconds in college football
but then gravity kicks in what goes up
must come down people wouldn't litter
something on the ground but then they
might not think twice about letting a
balloon go in the air
Danielle Vosburgh co-founded the
nonprofit balloons blow she considers
balloons litter and a threat to wildlife
they're just releasing them by the
thousands Vosburgh has targeted Clemson
and the University of Nebraska which has
its own balloon tradition she rented
this billboard in Lincoln urging the
school to end it she started cleaning
Florida beaches as a kid and says she
finds balloons that sailed hundreds of
miles and how often you found balloons
most of the time Vosburgh rejects the
industry's argument that latex balloons
are biodegradable in her backyard shed
she had stored six years worth of
balloons cleaned off nearby beaches
which tea was worth the latex of the
mylar I'd say the latex because those
are the ones more commonly found in the
stomach's of dead animals animals like
sea turtles and wild birds sometimes
mistake balloon fragments for food
environmentalists in the balloon
industry disagree
whether that threat can be fatal to
wildlife there's debate over how long
they take to break down but they are in
fact biodegradable Lorna O'Hara is
executive director of the balloon
council we don't dispute that they
sometimes find balloon fragments but
when they open them up there can be
anywhere between five and twenty five
things in their stomachs do you
understand why there is pressure to
remove balloons as a potential threat
yes but we would like to see people's
behavior changed
we're discouraging balloon releases but
we prefer education over legislation but
Vosburgh says it's time to pop the
balloons if they're so biodegradable how
come I still have some sit in my
backyard over six and a half years and
even if people stopped releasing
balloons today this balloon pollution
will still persist in the environment
and keep watching washing up along the
shores for many many years to come we
reached out to the University of
Nebraska they told us their balloons are
biodegradable and they use only paper
strengths as for clemson they're
planning a little switch instead of
balloons they're going to go with even
bigger fireworks shows all season long
Nora
mark all right thank you I like that
shot you did there was lots of balloons
in the midst of the living room for that
pet interview but that's getting people
thinking though about all kinds of
plastic that we're using the plastic
bags at grocery stores straws all of it
yeah I also wonder how fireworks affect
the environment yeah okay don't go after
fireworks too so America right I know
the cross the back cross my mind you
though yes